At least
14 people have been
killed in Ukraine, including children,
after a deadly barrage of Russian missile
missile strikes across the country.
CNN's Nic Robertson is live on the scene.
Human which is just south of Kiev.
Nick, I know this is the first strike in
or even around Kiev in a while, believe
since early March.
What can you tell us about
what's happened?
I know Ukraine had said
that they had intercepted
some of these, but what else?
What are you seeing on the damage
on the front Yeah.
The Ukrainian officials intercepted
most of those
missiles that were fired at Ukraine
and Kiev.
First time missiles were fired
on that city
in 51 days here in Oman
on some of the missiles
unfortunately got through.
This is a damage the rescue and recovery
they've been on this site
the missiles hit here about 9 hours ago.
If you look up there,
you can still see the smoke
coming out of the apartment building that
a missile
just slammed into this building.
We know that on site now.
And while we've been here,
we've seen another two bodies
carried out.
At least 15 people killed here.
We understand three of them children
we talked to an eyewitness
was one of the first people
on the scene here.
He said he could hear women and children
screaming in the rubble.
And I'm just going to walk you
through this rescue
and recovery operation
that's going on here right now.
There are fire trucks here
that are still putting water
on the blaze.
And if you follow me across here,
David, David's our camera
and follow me across here.
The families here
still waiting to find out
what's happened to their loved ones.
As you come around here,
you just get to see
how bad the devastation is
There's a line of firemen.
I don't know
if David, you can get in
to see them behind me,
but there's a line of firemen
scouring the ground there
where that digger is trying
to pull the rubble out.
This is an apartment building
that has 46 different apartments in it.
The missile strike here
at 5:00 in the morning
while people were sleeping.
So most of the victims so far,
we understand,
were all asleep in their beds.
There are dozens injured.
And frankly,
we've been talking to the officials here
They still don't
have a real, real accurate figure
of how many people
they're are still searching for.
One of the rescuers
we talked to a couple of minutes ago
told us they still believe
there's another
couple of children
in there
that they're trying to find
at the moment.
And there's a line of relatives
I'm looking at over there,
desperately waiting.
Distant just beyond
that big
crane there, desperately waiting for news
about their loved ones.
This is a slow and difficult process.
Of course, Ukraine
and the officials here
very, very familiar
with these devastating Russian strikes.
No matter how many of those missiles
they shoot down,
a couple still managed to get through.
And this is a result of it.
It's just horrifying for this community.
Yeah, you hear 21 of 23 intercepted
but look at the damage
of what did get through, what wasn't
successfully intercepted.
It speaks to, of course, when they say
they need defense systems for this.
But Nick,
I think what
you're talking about
is waiting to hear
what happened to their loved ones.
You can even imagine
what they're going through.
This is obviously a residential area.
It's what,
200 miles from the front line
of where the fighting actually goes.
Oh, it's a huge distance
from the front line.
You're right. About 200 miles.
And I'm looking around.
I mean, this apartment building here,
we're told by officials
109 people are registered living in here.
But I'm just going to ask
David to give us a quick spin
around this neighborhood.
And you see
how many other buildings are we?
We just look around here.
This is a dense residential neighborhood.
We're looking at here.
All around
there are buildings,
thousands of people,
thousands upon thousands of people
living here.
So even hundreds of miles
from the front line
and here in this city, Omar,
one to what a local residents
was telling us,
they haven't had a missile strike here
since March last year.
So for the people in these buildings
I'm looking at,
they're probably breathing
a sigh of relief
for the relatives desperately waiting.
But the reality for all of them,
it doesn't matter where you are
100 miles, 200, 300 from the front line.
You just don't know what can happen next.
Yeah. Absolute no sense of safety.
Nick, I know you'll be tracking this.
Will stay with you this morning.
Thank you.